okay - boys psychobabble we're resuming
I'm Hurst oh really
I really have no recollection of where
we were last and if we broke out fine
while the equipment akka okay mister
blaster which I will need some welding
equipment okay I thought okay now that
the Foxes [ __ ] Joe autos are they done
it yeah I'm so shady
I can take your peas okay I'm not gonna
take a piece see ya
hit but hello sir well you're so stupid
yes
look at that little [ __ ] crying okay
sorry I look at this map chat where's
our ring watch it be like in an [ __ ]
it can't have to be like obvious because
it's kind of hard to see a little
[ __ ] ring right are you eating it I
love to sneak up on that bench
oh these are the prisoners that got out
of their [ __ ] I just saw something Oh
what doctors bad oh man oh okay laughs
now
what is that laughs but rock your thing
okay I'm back okay so bring it what is
that noose is attached on the [ __ ]
hang himself
don't [ __ ] with that is s allows life
has started - what's in here [ __ ]
computer in here
that's one was he on the computer the
[ __ ] going on here the [ __ ] okay so
what every fire around here right take a
kid's board or something
that's weird
wait where's a cup row again where did I
come from
oh behind there get house slave now get
out of our [ __ ] house Rafi Oh Anya it
beautiful this [ __ ] [ __ ] Christ
Nicola why aren't you asleep I thought I
know to sleep no telling if I'll ever
wake up let me ask you something where
do you go when you lose consciousness I
even bother
what a surprise
you have a brain the brain is a
biological computational device running
an electrochemical process your
consciousness is an emergent property
absent process blank space like that of
a baby in other word view are your
electrochemical process fundamentally
you have the experience of a continuous
existence you are you at this point in
time the same you as you were in the
past and you have a sensation of writing
along this continuum of being you into
the future do you follow me
does it look like continuing allocations
the brain may be subjected to trauma and
put it early discontinuing the
electrochemical process such as a boxer
being knocked out as bittakers the brain
is no longer running its electrochemical
consciousness changes in process cancer
versus loss you lose consciousness pay
attention now at this point in time your
consciousness all that is you your
continuum of being you have ceased to
exist in the physical world
a woman's later the electrochemical
process needs to serve again allowing
consciousness to emerge out of the
information stored in the brain but I
wonder where are you in a meantime which
must we not assume so that the point
when consciousness is lost there are
some times if a new consciousness
appears or not in the same brain is
entirely inconsequential to the desk
a new consciousness is simply a new
person because it emerges from the same
brain it has access to all the memories
and cognitive structures at the dead
consciousness so it thinks it is the
same person as in actuality just an
impostor inheriting the body and brain
from the previous now dead inhabitant
fits into a child there what about the
soul
there is no such thing as a soul we have
machines of biology nothing more nothing
less idiotic there so is simply a
pointless concept dreamt up by priests
and fairy they're men you're an anomaly
you an outlier useless what's up [ __ ]
and there's like what the [ __ ]
what to make of you wide mouth no here
to help me you seen beyond help
what are you working on gathering data
Nazi activity
behavioral patterns program rustling the
mass developing predictions where are
they allocating resources where will
they strike next
and after that what ever larger trends
triggering their actions figure out what
choices they will make before they make
them we talk as if the future is
inevitable as if all our choices have
already been made you think there is
such a thing as free will you know so
little of the world you want to be the
captain of your faith do you this site
you will lose you cannot go to war
against physics my actions are my own I
know that much
only phenomena in the physical world
follow the simple rule of cause and
effect your brain is no exception to the
rule no the causes you can predict the
effect the same is true for everything
so what's with the ores are preparing
for the end I never want my road leads
and I intend to take as many Nazis with
me as I can muster you have any
experience with firearms
of course by bay
our eyes finally opened up well I really
should not have decided to take a nap oh
okay I was going to ask her if I
thinking that looks nice
let's get what is it what is it hello
sir
[ __ ] that headquarter map archives
archives aren't going to show me chef
please you're eating die kind of find
this [ __ ] ring where's the ring if
I'm the ring ya find the man okay I was
sleeping in here
no I wasn't sleeping you yeah no I
wasn't this is a Ferguson room see if I
can take the ring
nobody knows Oh what is that in the
hangar have you stinker in with mlah
hunters and what is this
eva is welder right okay where are the
rings ha I say yeah pop them ok s tepid
batch got that what would someone's been
studying up on helicopters fry yes
I guess I should go down and see what's
going on really nice
allow sir
- [ __ ] you tell a [ __ ] you will never
be the same as Bob Bob you will never
live up an yabber yabber your answers
are you not yeah you're [ __ ] crazy
you won't loss Colette's looking for the
welder you seen it no I don't think so
no wait a minute no you're right you're
right I was being to sort out the
railing over by the secret five mansions
[ __ ] fell out of my hand into the
water
I'll bet busy at the moment but you're
the well that you go right on ahead and
start swimming the dog is in the main
room behind the tape well that's good
Sizzix such a [ __ ] now okay so look
okay
all over there
are these guys still talking
yeah so this should lead somewhere right
now should be like all the way in the
back holy [ __ ] Baba you're lying
sorry pal don't mean to you know derail
your train of thought look I need to get
through that dog please what I think
about I'd rather not think about that
bad do you think that when Jason was I
have till 9:00 with Greg like an egg how
come it is not or maybe it has begun
already and I just don't know it moral
changes matter who you are what you made
up thing is you and me we just got to
ride the whirlwind make it through to
the other side if you kill all the Nazis
and kill all and I never kill sorry not
you in celebration veneers at time come
your arm and bucket it not said wait
what the [ __ ] is no way back great
okay ash we're going to go but let me
just check to make sure there's no
[ __ ] yeah that's all in there I can't
tell the [ __ ] is that shrimp
dad this is this dirty water I mean I
was just some straight-up dirty water
croc probably [ __ ] crocodiles and
[ __ ]
well I'm just saying that because
there's crocodiles and [ __ ] you know
and whooping I then they take a shower
in their solution [ __ ] we'll work
our way backwards
oh don't mind if I show ok I've jumped
over here
now where the [ __ ] am I going nobody
knows nobody seems to care about all
psychobabble okay am I missing something
Oh
yeah that's some that are here holy [ __ ]
can I shoot it from here yes
flexion was that
[Music]
it's [ __ ] loud out over there above
us and now actually here
I don't know zero but their gear me up
for something
here we go
[ __ ] a robot bottle and it's battery
charger so [ __ ] egg here we go
oh [ __ ]
but
come this way fool watch out cha cha cha
cha charge now scary [ __ ] as you use
that what's in here it's going to slow
me down or what [ __ ] that was scary
anyone in here
[ __ ] egg there we go here we go
breasts and I sure would hate to cross
me [ __ ] going through like these
pipes with this [ __ ] machine gun holy
[ __ ] we're like so close to [ __ ] out
this all this work lousy welder next
time you will get it Fergus has an idea
ring yet man kind of you upstairs on
right
imagine being free from [ __ ] like one
of those Holocaust up Waco's things
camps nice you [ __ ] take it I bet you
took it [ __ ] I bet you [ __ ] took it
where's that blue thing amazing could
you take it where do you take it this is
where I naps and that lady [ __ ] watch
me like you think that's it first you're
going to look crazy there
I checked upstairs in a while huh okay
the great flying here that's our
borrowed welder Fergus
where's the ring nightmare no thank you
I'm gone what nightmares okay I'm trying
to cut this thing [ __ ] here's that ring
out there check this room
what the [ __ ] is that way yes yes how
looking for a ring it's not all you [ __ ]
is the ring to delete it back Oh
actually would you deliver this note to
only human
[ __ ] right there both of the trucks but
I gag on goddamned errand boy and we do
another sweep though for that's a ring
because this is basically it for
Louisville we don't feel like sticking
in with way to find this ring then tune
out interesting now I still have not
found here wearing sari it's [ __ ]
gone it's [ __ ] gone
I don't want to take any weird shortcuts
because I'm going to miss a spot
okay real one here when you [ __ ] a lot
handle it getting really low mail out
what do you get
I know you have the [ __ ] ring just
give it to me
[Music]
I'm going to [ __ ] to that ring yo
Esteban what are you down here
tools [ __ ] that
I don't know where the [ __ ] ring went
sucks to suck out
okay that's what I'm the mission oh yeah
do you have a moment
[ __ ]
we don't always share like this always
it will happen William what she learnt
jizan her know it's ready right let's go
[ __ ] no no you are now inside source
narrows the intestinal tracts of a city
and de beaupré no sir Berlin chemicals
the fist complex the more secure site in
ovarian the central munition stockpile
of the Nazi regime two things because of
results went right for your vote
water locked in editable to outsiders
just only one rate weeks across the
perimeter
it's a tunnel glider so Nazis use and
for meetings down there we've been
trying for years to bring it up to
working order plant okay fair